[Musik]
szene aus dem selbst gedrehten video
eines krimis die hamburger reeperbahn
mit einer goldenen pistole in der hand
droht ein mann auf tschetschenisch
[Musik]
jeden der unsere anführer ramzan kadyrov
kritisiert werde ich mit dieser pistole
erschießen wir sind hier in deutschland
wir kontrollieren das hier wenn jemand
denkt ich bleibe komm her allah ist groß
dass mittlerweile gelöschten video wurde
von einem der wohl mächtigsten
tschetschenen deutschlands auf instagram
geteilt timo doga sei er ist einer der
engsten getreuen des diktators ramzan
kadirow der tschetschene ein mann der
seine gegner bedrohen und drangsalieren
soll
des diktators tröster helferteam motto
kasajew 39 jahre alt gemeldet in kiel ex
kampfsportler box promoter und sogar
cdu-mitglied äußerlich ein demokrat doch
die welt ist schienen hat eine dunkle
seite er ist bestens verdrahtet in die
internationale unterwelt und er ist der
offizielle vertreter kadir offs in
europa seit 14 jahren regiert ramzan
kadyrov tschetschenien eine autonome
teilrepublik russland ein mini reich im
nordkaukasus mit knapp anderthalb
millionen einwohnern die meisten davon
sind muss lied von moskau gestützten der
despot mit eiserner hand
menschenrechtsorganisationen werfen ihm
morde folter und entführungen vor seinen
kritikern droht der 44 jährige diktator
in öffentlichen netzwerken hier wie
instagram story
[Gelächter]
westliche sicherheitsbehörden vermuten
kann dir aufs regime hinter attentaten
auf tschetschenische dissidenten erst im
dezember 2020 setzt die in die us
regierung zusammen mit seinem
europäischen stellvertreter timo kasajew
auf eine sanktionsliste der vorwurf
schwere verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit
unmenschliches hat auch selim erlebt der
tschetschenische regimekritiker lebt
seit vier jahren im deutschen exil in
berlin fünf jahre lang saß der mann in
der republik hauptstadt grosny im
gefängnis und wurde von kadyrows leuten
brutal gefoltert wir treffen ihn an
einem geheimen ort aus angst vor pathos
rache müssen wir den vater eines sohnes
unkenntlich machen
kann die ruß regime das heißt wenn du
kadyrows regeln nicht befolgt oder kadir
auf und zeigen erfolge nicht magst dann
bist du der feind so funktioniert das
kann er auch regie
sie erfanden einen strafprozess und
folterten mich zwei wochen lang bis ich
endlich gestand einer bewaffneten
widerstands gruppe angehört zu haben
im gefängnis haben sie mich dann am
ersten tag mit elektroschocks gefoltert
am zweiten und dritten tag schlugen sich
mit einer keule traten mich und schlugen
mich mit kabeln und so schon genug
himmlische in der letzten woche übten
sie psychischen druck auf mich aus und
bedrohten meine verwandten
selim ist gerade mal 18 jahre alt als er
von kadir aufs regime auf offener
strasse verhaftet und deportiert wird
ich habe sehr viel durchgemacht ich
wollte mein heimatland nie verlassen
aber als sie meine familie angriffen
ging es nicht mehr sie haben meine
schwangere frau vor meinen augen
geschlagen auf den bauch sie haben mein
ungeborenes kind geschlagen als es bei
ihren bauch war verstehen sie damit
haben sie mich endgültig gebrochen und
ich bin dann mit meiner familie nach
deutschland
[Musik]
ich wollte immer wieder zurück nach
tschetschenien aber wissen sie ich kann
nicht
sobald ich die grenze erreicht
russisches territorium betreten war es
das dann kann ich mich nicht nur von
tschetschenien sondern der ganzen welt
verabschieden
doch auch in deutschland seinem
zufluchtsort scheint selim nicht sicher
zu sein der verlängerte arm kadir offs
reicht sogar bis ins zentrum europas bis
nach berlin ziehen weiß dass er auch
hiervon gradierung schergen beobachtet
wird
lukas ist eine der hauptfiguren die
informationen dort hinschicken und
flüchtlinge in deutschland und anderen
europäischen ländern in angst und
schrecken halten
[Musik]
denn wenn man vor kadir aus leuten
flieht denkt man das war's jetzt bin ich
frei aber man ist es nicht es ist hart
timo togaf lebt ein leben in protz und
prunk offenbar finanziert von
tschetschenischen regierungsgeldern
erfährt schicke autos besitzt euro
buchen auf dem papier scheint eher
unauffällig hat kaum relevante
vorstrafen enorm jedoch sein einfluss in
der tschetschenischen community dort
gilt er als eine art pate unnachgiebig
autoritär und kompromisslos seine
verbindungen sollen tief in die
organisierte kriminalität reichen leider
muss man feststellen dass
tschetschenische gruppierung eigentlich
seit jahrzehnten auch gerade im bereich
der organisierten kriminalität immer
wieder auftauchen ja auch mit schwersten
straftaten auftauchen es ist immer wenig
in die öffentlichkeit gelangt muss man
auch ganz ehrlich sein das hat jetzt in
den letzten jahren ein bisschen
zugenommen und sie wohnen in der
vergangenheit immer ganz gern so als
würde ein gesetz ja wenn es um
schutzgeld abrechnung beispielsweise
gingen oder wenn es um rivalitäten im
bereich der aok gab hat man die
tschetschenen geschickt und dann war
erstmal ruhe gebracht jetzt hat man in
den letzten jahren gemerkt dass sie auch
so ein bisschen nicht mehr diese jobs
wollen sondern wo wir um ein großes
stück vom kuchen abhaben selbst
geschäfte übernehmen und man sieht dass
in einzelnen bezirken in einzelnen
bereichen schon beim bereich des
waffenhandels in der drogenkriminalität
dass sie da schon eigentlich
vorgesprochen
wie groß der einfluss von chagaev aber
in kriminellen kreisen tatsächlich zu
sein scheint zeigen auseinandersetzungen
zwischen tschetschenen und mitgliedern
des berüchtigten aus dem libanon
stammenden remo platz am 8 november 2020
in berlin
tschetschenen schlagen mit hämmern und
stöcken auf den rivalen 1 diese rächen
sich am folgetag sie haben einem mann
ein messer in den rücken und prügeln
brutal auf ihre feinde ein es droht ein
klacks
[Musik]
bei dem streit werden mindestens 20
männer zum teil schwer verletzt
die hintergründe sind noch unklar es
soll um drogengeschäfte gegangen sein
wenn man rivalitäten im bereich der
organisierten kriminalität hat und
gerade über arabische großfamilien oder
auch über tschetschenische gruppierung
spricht dann stellt man schon fest dass
da nicht nur das messer und der
baseballschläger ganz locker sitzen
sondern dass man auch zur schusswaffe
greifen
das ist ein welt gesetzt das ist ganz
schlimm dass sie die leute hier sind
weil sie aufträge ausführen das ist das
wichtigste für kadyrov menschen in
europa zu haben die für ihn arbeiten
dass man ja was von welt besuchen herrn
douglas a f der wohnt auch hier oder
jedes mal wenn ich irgendwo hingehe weiß
ich dass ich vielleicht nicht
zurückkehren werde so gefährlich ist es
gar die ruff zu kritisieren
[Musik]